but hey what do I know I'm just a guy
who encourages people to rape on
Saturday night title nine campus rape is
an important topic because it ruins
people's lives
let's set this for people who don't
really know we just throw around the
term and that's you DeVos and tide line
okay
headline is a portion of the United
States education amendments from 1972
and this is what it says no person in
the United States shall on the basis of
sex be excluded from participation in be
denied the benefits of or be subjected
to discrimination under any education
program or activity receiving federal
financial assistance so how does this
come to have any relevance to campus
sexual assault okay 2011 Obama's
Education Department wrote a Dear
Colleague letter to all colleges
outlining new procedures for detailing
and dealing it detailed and should not a
deal with campus sexual assault so what
did this do it reinterpreted title nine
is actually giving the federal
government the authority to dictate all
of the procedures that colleges would
use to address sexual assault
allegations they said by the way excited
if you read this go we have a link to
the PDF cited all the research like the
one in five women are raped I don't know
if the 77 cents in this this is the
president sending out we're gonna reform
this because one in five women are raped
yeah the people reading this do that
Google Google no no okay we're going to
say yeah we just have to go with one
five right verifiably folks and that's
where that's where you get
conspiratorial it's just a prep does the
President of the United States not know
that that's untrue
so this required universities based on
this fall to these false sort of
premises to allow accusers by the way to
appeal not guilty findings which is
basically a form of looks like a
violation of double jeopardy yeah so the
most important point here is that the
Obama administration actually demanded
that colleges use what's called the
lower burden of proof now it's not just
terminology it's actually a legal term
so this means that instead of proving
beyond a reasonable doubt as we have to
do in our legal system the accuser when
it dealt with campus rape only had to
prove that it was likely basically
possible that a sexual assault could
happen were you alive on Wednesday then
it could have had a jury of my peers no
she's already carrying the serta
your peers are now kangaroos it is true
these are effectively kangaroo courts
these are these it's like Lord of the
Flies on campus so this is this is what
happened a record number of people have
been expelled for sexual assault with no
evidence at all more than a hundred
people have or are now suing
universities for violating their due
process rights so this is important
because the attack against Betsy DeVos
will talk with Roman millennial about it
hint not everyone agrees with angry
feminists the attack is well she's
condoning rape you see that down planned
apparently it from Cecile Ridge you see
from all these people on - I can't
believe every woman every woman who
claims a victim of sexual assault
deserves to be heard what about the guy
who's been accused of sexual assault who
didn't do it we can play that game - you
can play that game an either side of it
and this is how they try to paint it if
you somehow oppose the interpretation of
title nine which Betsy DeVos does which
has destroyed countless lives you're a
rapist that's what we wanted to get into
is now what is this done in practice
let's give you some examples because
everyone knows you know mattress girl
right yeah mattress girl UVA the Rolling
Stone Duke Lacrosse so these are ones
that everyone knows but again hundreds
of people are suing because of violation
of the due process right so let's give
you some examples of title nine abuse
that you might not know about so Amherst
College 2012 male student passed out at
a party after drinking too much while he
was unconscious his girlfriend's
roommate performed fellatio I guess will
say this is going on broadcast on him so
she texted her friends about it this is
an actual story this is actually
probably even way worse than magistral I
don't know why I didn't get the same
press direct quote in the text was oh my
god I just did something so effing
stupid she was worried a roommate would
never talk to her again because of what
she'd done and she texted quote it's
pretty obvious a an innocent bystander
now she wasn't raped
but for using the term obvi someone
could understand why one might be one my
aggressive with her yeah so two years
later after this she accused him of
sexual assault the result the guy was
expelled when the girl's friend came
forward with texts showing that she was
actually the guilty party the college
refused to open the case now keep in
mind the guilty man in this case was
never even charged with a crime so this
is another example of Amherst College a
mess she blew a guy in his sleep and
then two years later said she
sexually assaulted there was evidence to
the contrary in this guy's life is
ruined this is not a typical by the way
if you like the whole like the timeline
is so we're going to see this like if
you got violently raped in an alley
right now would you like realize that
like a couple years down the road maybe
guys I'm more that'd be like I'm never
falling asleep again maybe I was raped
the University of Findlay Ohio here's
another one in 2014 so jut here's
something often title nine effects pay
people off of my no minority status on
campus people don't realize that what do
you do miss possibly rearrange the
priorities Justin browning and Alfonso
Beatty the second two black athletes so
each had a separate sexual encounters
with a white female student one Saturday
night September 14 at a party okay
according to witnesses she initiated
both encounters they were consensual she
even came out of the room between
encounters and paraded in front of other
friends naked
in the residence now this doesn't mean
she's guilty should be sexually assault
a note that's not at all what I'm saying
don't say we're rape apologist she then
spent the entire night with Justin
browning and bragged to several friends
afterward regarding the sexual
encounters okay thirteen days later she
filed a sexual assault complaint against
both men only two days later they were
both expelled now before even providing
rounding up ad with any chance to appeal
the decision the school actually issued
a campus-wide alert announcing their
expulsion and their names and photos
were printed in a local paper it's like
an Amber Alert for fake rape I just
don't get why my wife doesn't doesn't
parade after our sexual encounters she
does she talked to me about it
she never parades she says I look a
shame what are you trying to say we just
were you just make a joke with man's
wife no you could probably reach over
there and kick his ass right no I'm
already planning it the University by
the way never followed up with any kind
of evidence and they denied the appeals
again they were never charged with a
crime let alone found guilty here's one
that I find interesting and the reason
why is because you know we see all these
bullying anti-bullying campaigns and
ileft same people who hope that Betsy
DeVos gets raped but you know the rules
get a little murky so gay male student
the University of Texas at Arlington -
he excused Thomas clock it could be
cloaked I could be mispronouncing it
here he accused Thomas clock of writing
anti-gay slurs
on his computer during class so
basically they was like he wrote an
anti-gay slur and turned it over to the
gay guy okay he wrote apparently all gay
should die into a search bar and turn
and then called the gay student it's in
it so this so basically there was no
evidence okay
the administration admitted there was no
evidence and clock actually said that
the gay student had been hitting on him
typing your beautiful into his search
bar and showing a two man clock
responded hey stop I'm straight and
asked him to leave which by the way is
borderline
committing a hate crime nowadays just
saying no to a gay man is seen as far
more aggressive than a woman saying no
to a male believe me I've had this
happen in the workplace
why don't you say no to uh happens boys
sure know what your problem with gay
guys what no I'm just I'm just not gay
well is that what it is you're
homophobic I I'm just not a homosexual
this is a fanny pack only zone though so
the gay student was friends this is the
important note a friends with the
associate VP of Student Affairs Heather
snow she then went on to write a
complaint for the gay student and
punished the alleged man in question
without even contacting the title nine
coordinator at the school now Clark
never received a hearing he was
prohibited from having contact with
anyone in the class which meant that it
was impossible for him to contact any
witnesses to corroborate his story the
ears to the school still required him to
take exams for classes that he was
prohibited from attending he was placed
on academic probation and the
Disciplinary record was gonna keep him
out of grad school which he'd planned on
attending so that's it sounds try this
is important because he'd planned on
attending grad school all of this no
evidence the person happened to be
friends with a vice president over that
the committee days after all this clock
killed himself no history of mental
health problems by all accounts happy
looking forward to graduation moving on
to grad school here's what's important
for people to understand rape is a
horrible crime and I think every guy in
this room would say yeah rape is
terrible I don't think anyone here wants
this anyone raped I think if we knew a
man who were an actual rapist we
probably beat him within an inch of his
life
but it is life-destroying to simply
throw the accusation of rape especially
on campus where it follows you for the
rest of your life there's nothing
you can do about it think about that
imagining all of your life's plans are
destroyed by a gay guy with an axe to
grind who's friends with someone who
happened to be a VP over there in a
title line Department can you imagine
how hopeless that would be this is again
that culture of victims we need to
appease these creating actual victims
where's the anti-bullying campaign here
hey say no to hate don't bully the kid
with a lisp
well you drew you drove a guy to killing
himself because you didn't even allow
him the legal tools that are available
to anyone not at your university it is
you were talking about this before when
we did the show was it was a really good
point on when you were talking about you
know you have a choice of as a guy being
them being the monster yeah the monster
yeah I mean I just bummed me out man
that's crazy
well like would you right no no it's
it's just like uh I mean that other guy
is such a nobody honestly though like
that bad will get a celebrity video
where a bunch of people say the same
phrase do you know do you know do you
know when you say it but doesn't matter
if he just falsely accuse a guy of rape
I was just in Europe for two weeks so I
believe he was a bundle of sticks yes
that's a call a pack of cigarettes it's
changed meaning for a long time that an
episode of that on South Park you know
gives so much power just two words that
hurt people's feelings and then remove
powers from institutions that allow us
to protect ourselves legally as per the
Constitution we want everyone to be
afraid of but we don't want them to
actually have the ability to protect
themselves which hey that's kind of the
founding of our country should
constitutional rights apply to a student
yeah if he's an American citizen these
are the same people who want us to apply
constitutional rights to people who are
not American citizens but we require no
actual proof beyond a reasonable doubt
to ruin a man's life for the rest of his
life and if you speak out against it
you're a rape abala gist this is why
title 9 is so important and even if you
don't like Betsy DeVos I don't think she
was most experienced we'll talk about
this with Roman lemme I'm sure she has
some opinions when you look again it
makes you kind of like with Donald Trump
it makes me have to defend her more
because there absolutely needs to be a
change here you will destroy a
generation of men forever but hey what
do I know I'm just a guy who encourages
people to rape on Saturday night
if you like this video subscribe by
clicking the button that says subscribe
if you're not aware of it now there's no
way you're learning the Internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively to lotto with credit calm /
mug club members of your student
military or veteran internet promo code
it's less than six dollars a month and
you get daily content no more clips Plus
this hand etched mug oh I just when I
feel it I got a chill like on the inside